hey vincent how are you
all right good
um so i interviewed you a couple weeks
ago for the hour
you were so good in it i asked you about
kingpin and you obviously kept that a
secret for me which i understand does it
feel good now that you can actually talk
about it it does yeah it does feel good
yeah
is that fun for you getting to lie to
people and keep it a secret or is there
like pressure to that well
i it's kind of cheating to ask me that
question because i'm gonna throw back at
you that um
that i'm going to do uh
that i know right off the bat that i
know very little about anything and that
and that um i'm happy that i know very
little so i don't have to keep as many
secrets as you think i might be keeping
that's good
is that by choice
that you don't know much
no it's actually you know the good thing
about it is it's limited to what i i
know
yeah uh that goes even you know i
you know i get shot at the end of
hawkeye you know like she shoots me i
know
yeah and so i have no idea what happens
after that i i can only hope that the
character continues you know i just have
no idea and and
but
you know
it's you know when daredevil ended years
ago you know i walked away from it very
happy you know
so
who knows you know
are you lying now
no actually actually
i believe that i believe that
um so let's talk about the finale
because it was so good can you have this
epic uh face off with haley steinfeld
obviously with kate bishop there well
how fun is that shooting that scene it
was amazing you know haley's really
something else you know i mean i i wish
that i had gotten to act with her in
actual dialogue scenes and stuff we had
a little bit of dialogue in that scene
but not much and
she's just so
honest as an actress you know she's just
so good and
and you know she's her worth ethic is
her work ethic is amazing and
i don't know i was very impressed by her
it was really fun it was um i think you
know thank god we have this
we had this incredible stunt team and
she you know it's it's all very
impressive to me i have to tell you it's
really something yeah it was a really
good time
you know we haven't seen kingpin your
kingpin in a couple of years and you
almost forget what a force he is what
was that like for you stepping back into
kingston's shoes
so fun
it's so fun i got to play him very
similar to the way that i did he's
stronger physically you know more
stronger it can take more physical abuse
but his emotional state and the way he
is as a as a as a person
he's you know i'm playing him exactly
the same and
and and so it's it's great
it's great fun and you know it's he's
very
you know
very deep and and full of a lot of pain
like i said which is not fun when the
camera's rolling sometimes but
overall it's just this exciting
opportunity you know
and very quickly to wrap things up you
know a lot with cox she's getting her
own spin-off series and we know that
echo and kingston are very
you know they're they're together a lot
in the comics is there a possibility
that kingpin could appear on the
spin-off series
i hope so i don't know you know we'll
see i i do know the
i'm very familiar with the comic runs
that they had because i when i was doing
my research for daredevil early you know
in the earlier series years ago
that was one of the
my favorite
comet runs
was the relay father-daughter
relationship
of them so one can only hope you know
i like that answer awesome so nice game
to talk to you again
bye thank you
you